everyone keeps secrets
sometimes it's the only way to protect
the ones we love
[Music]
i know you
god killer
what is it you want from me
is it a god of war you came to find
[Music]
you don't really want war
do your kratos
all that blood on your hands
and your son's hands
what is it you will not tell me
i can't talk about it
but i just need you to trust me we
follow your every whim but you don't
believe in any of it and still i follow
because all that matters is that you are
safe but that's not all that matters
who's keeping you safe
i do not need you to protect me
sure about that
pretender god
for the old father death can have me
when it comes me
in your lifetimes has anyone ever
worshipped you
ever prayed to you
can you even imagine that kind of love
no
you don't care about anything beyond
yourself
beyond the monster who kills without
cause
[Music]
fate only bind you if you let it
do what's necessary
not because it is written
[Music]
we will make our own destiny
[Music]
playstation